yeah so do you do you feel like um
having a high body count as a girl has
consequences
um i think it does um i i think it does
and like even from experience i think
that's it some guys will be like this
turns me off but then i'm like okay then
you're you're yeah for me it's
compatibility
i think compatibility is so important so
would you tell a young woman to sleep
around and like explore their sexuality
or would you tell them to keep your body
count as low as possible so you can get
the best quality husband um
i would say what what is important to
you
and some people that's it some people
see some people sleep around for
validation and they'll be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like i have had
casual sex because i enjoy sex
that's the right long and short of it i
enjoy sex
um
female sexual liberation i'm all here
for it yeah um but i used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and i got to a
point in like late 2020 where i was like
i don't want to do that anymore because
i've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and i ended up in
relationships where i thought the men
were my league
but they didn't respect me so then i
dated men who were under my league who
adored me and then i was like you're not
enough
well do you yeah do you think maybe they
were actually your league because like
you can't say that someone was your
league if they weren't able to commit to
you like your league is who you can get
to commit to you but then this comes to
the success and ambition and blah blah
blah and like right but remember men and
women are valued for different things
yeah so
i settled for men that were short and
broke
i settled for men but they could say
like they settled for you with a high
body count but they could they could say
the same thing but they are men that
literally the men that i settled for
were men that literally were like they
look at me in the morning and be like
you're the most beautiful person in the
world and i was like no i'm not you're
incorrect i you i was like you literally
you expect too too little i get you some
behavior i get you different behavior
behavior yeah like
i was gonna say i think there is a i
think there is a middle yeah between um
between
uh a girl getting a guy
because i get what you're saying yeah
like for for girls your league isn't who
you can sleep with your league is who
you can get who can get to commit to you
but what i would say is that a lot of
girls date guys who could have committed
to them but because they've dated them
in a certain way they've put themselves
in the friends of benefit zone so now
that's not
on the table does that make sense so i
think there is like you know for sure
like there is like a you know like oh if
a guy's a nine and he's sleeping with a
girl who's quoting quite a five that
she's probably never gonna commit to her
right but it's possible that okay for
guys in eight who gets a lot of
attention he may sleep with a girl as an
eight but if she
plays it wrong he might think oh she's
hot
like she's very attractive because she's
not girlfriend i think guys go down and
looks all the time i'm not like dis but
just sex yeah i'm not discounting that
but what i'm saying like as a girl it's
still what you can get to commit because
that's still you it's your it's your
choices yeah
right it's true but i think i think
girls don't um
i think a lot of girls
do date guys who could have committed to
them
it's just because the way they dated
them the guy was like well she's not
girlfriend material yeah and then this
does come back to body count because
i've had an experience where recently a
guy is like well i've not dated anyone
since you i get a bit jealous when you
tell me you want to end things and i'm
like you've told me you're not going to
commit to me you're not going to be
serious about me i'm never going to be
your girlfriend i'm like but you are
serious about me and to be fair body
count doesn't actually relate to our
situation
but
oh there's just so many like
really like intricate details and it's
not it's not necessarily like practical
in this day and age right because again
the average age of first marriage is 27.
like guys used to marry virgins and now
like guys don't even like want virgins
yeah but that's it it's that whole
whole black and white situation where a
guy you know
a lot of it's about ego and a lot of it
yeah a lot of it is about people's
self-worth and self-esteem
and i did have a really good point to
say oh it's about um attractiveness even
that so i used to go off the ethos to a
blind person with all the same so i gave
a lot of people chances and i used to go
on dates with anyone because i just
don't do that i'm like
don't don't don't do it and this sounds
so awful but like so i did that i was
like what are you gonna do give them
pity sex like
i used to pity i didn't say that i used
to pick not not so i used to pity kiss
people i give people my phone number and
be like i don't really want to give you
my phone but maybe if you're showing me
interest
and a guy so this is why i say
undervalued or underwhelmed yeah so that
was what i ended up in i used to be like
guys that i thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me loved me really valued me i
was like oh you're underwhelming i don't
think that you match up and that's why
i've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because i'm like i don't
want to get hurt i don't i don't want to
hurt anyone but i don't get hurt and i
was like i'm actually you're also you're
you're also competing for a small
percentage of guys too that you're
probably attracted you know that only
like 10
i don't even i don't know the exact stat
but
i've heard numbers from 5 to 15 of
dating app swipes are i don't use dating
apps i don't usually don't use anything
no and it's because dating apps do tend
to be a black and white party in that
you've either got people on there who
are like i just want something casual
nice not nothing serious
um or you've got people who are like i'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like i want a
relationship ergo i'm looking for
someone who can
fill that criteria so when they go on
dates when they swipe they're like i'm
literally thinking about
are you going through your relationship
material
or
there's people like me i'm bottom up
where i'm like i'd rather just meet
someone and be like
where is this gonna go let's live in
there now let's take it date by date but
you think that women it would be better
for women if we dated more intentionally
because to me it's like
if you could be single you could be
single let's say you're single for five
years you're in a relationship for five
years
like i would think that the girl would
probably be less like heartbroken and
had less trauma if she was in a
relationship for five years
because i mean assuming he's not
narcissist assume assuming there's no
abuse narcissism like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like i don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like like you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time
better is subjective like eat pray love
is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful and
she's like i'm actually not happy i'm
actually not like i'd like to circle
back with that lady yeah that turned out
yeah
and it's like
there are there are people who sometimes
wake up and go [ __ ] i'm not happy and i
should be happy i hate the concept of
should and so i'm i'm a really big
advocate for like difference do you do
you think happiness like comes and goes
oh yeah like like do you think you
should just leave a relation a
relationship with like kids and stuff if
you're not happy so